si es un movimiento que nace en tick
tock hace varias semanas y parte del
famoso tick tock r eduardo medina un
inmigrante de padre uruguayo y madre
mexicana que llegó aquí con cinco años y
ahora tiene 23 y por eso lucha por los
derechos de los inmigrantes básicamente
lo que consiste este movimiento es que
es impedir a los inmigrantes que vive en
eeuu que hoy no vayan a trabajar que hoy
no lleven a sus pequeños a la escuela
que no hagan compras en ningún negocio
para que el país se dé cuenta de cómo
sería aquí la rutina diaria si estos
inmigrantes no vivieran en eeuu se ha
creado una página de facebook en la que
hay a cerca de 85 mil seguidores y lo
que se pretende es lanzar un mensaje
claro y alto a washington de la
importancia de aprobar cuanto antes una
reforma migratoria este movimiento a va
a dar lugar a manifestaciones en diez
ciudades principales los ángeles
washington miami nueva york aquí cuenta
también con el apoyo de la congresista
demócrata
alexandra ocasio cortes y además cuenta
con el apoyo de otros políticos en todo
el país que también han querido unirse
y movimiento al que también se han unido
muchas muchas organizaciones y
asociaciones que aseguran que ya vimos
la importancia de los inmigrantes en
este país durante la pandemia cuando se
recogieron las peores cifras entre
latinos en cuanto a contagios de kobe 19
porque ellos eran los que estaban en esa
primera línea en los hospitales en los
negocios esenciales dicen las
organizaciones y sacando adelante al
país mientras que los norteamericanos
estaban en su casa protegiéndose el
coronavirus así que por eso hoy quieren
volver a remarcar la importancia de los
inmigrantes el valor que tienen los
inmigrantes en este país